Buenos días Hoy es un día muy especial
en este momento se enciende la señal de
France 24 en español el nacimiento de un
canal Franz 24 en español emitió por
primera vez el 26 de septiembre de 2017
desde Bogotá la capital colombiana
pensando en una mayor cercanía con
América Latina y a diferencia de los
canales en inglés francés y árabe la
cadena de habla hispana se estableció en
la región siendo la única redacción de
France 24 que se encuentra fuera de
París el canal comenzaba a expandirse a
partir de hoy Franz 24 en español crece
dos años después Franz 24 en español
duplicó sus horas de antena a 12 horas
de información en vivo en medio de este
proceso un desafío sin precedentes
estamos por el momento llevándoles una
programación de noticias más corta de lo
habitual la pandemia de Kobe 19 la
emergencia sanitaria nos impactó pero
nunca detuvimos nuestra operación y
damos el paso a nuestras 24 horas de
programación
en español francés 24 en español dio el
Salto a las 24 horas de información
continua en vivo el 24 de septiembre de
2021 y lo hizo de la mano de lanzamiento
de directo América el primer magazine de
actualidad de lunes a viernes de la
cadena muy buenas noches América Latina
Bienvenidos a esta primera edición de
directo a América el canal reforzó su
Apuesta por las franjas de información
con directo América edición nocturna que
comenzó a emitirse en abril de 2022
Franz 24 en español estrena ahora
Expreso de Oriente y así es Asia además
de una semana en el mundo y refuerza la
presencia de contenidos en podcast
emitimos en 18 de los 19 territorios de
habla hispana de América Latina así como
Brasil y Estados Unidos tenemos 3
millones de espectadores cada semana y
más de un millón de suscriptores en
YouTube una redacción de 70 periodistas
con una red de 50 corresponsales 5 años
de aprendizaje y consolidación en la
oferta la televisión internacional con
un futuro en el que nuestro compromiso
sigue siendo el mismo brindarles una
información contrastada de calidad e
interés general